you're a pisces right so
um you live in the ethers
um it's a super dreamy state of being
and you're an artist which makes sense
and you're empathic and you can feel
other people
and so living in the moment is guided by
spirit which is always the best way
you're good you are good
now now you are very good at
articulating yourself um
you know i i i'm fascinated by the human
condition i'm fascinated by reality
and human nature and um you know
everything down to like are we a
simulation are we zeros and ones is this
where do we go when we die and what is
consciousness and
you know what are dimensions and like i
mean i just and
and and how the human operates on this
in this density level are you
are you getting closer to those answers
every day
um i mean i have my own conclusions
right now
like right i think that's the the the
fun part about
learning is that um and experiences is
that
uh as you collect them and as being an
open-minded person
i believe what i believe right now but
that might be different in uh
two months or two years and in fact i
hope it is because it means that i will
have
collected more information that helps me
make a better better judgment or
assessment of what's really going on um
so i'm fascinated with with with how
people operate and and i think that we
can be kind of broken down into patterns
which is totally what makes me think we
might be zeros and ones like elon musk
says
um yeah i know i i i mean
i like bounce between it every day
because like i do
look like my favorite thing is like i
try to tell people like i'm always like
yo yeah there is you have a witness at
all times
at all times this is why i say movie all
the time because i'm like
when you're by yourself like when i'm by
myself
in my room and i wake up i'll make it a
point to be like
yeah love is good and i'm dancing and
i'm going like this because i'm like i
am doing that for myself but i'm also
doing that to show
the witness that i'm special i'm here
i'm
understanding that like i don't have to
show up when people are watching i need
to show up always
you know and like i love to just to just
help people be aware that like everyone
deserves a witness
and like the things that you do
when you're alone are almost far more
important than the things you do for a
crowd
you know and so the idea of a simulation
is like it runs so deep with me
as far as like someone's watching
you know someone is watching me and i
want to be have you ever seen the movie
vanilla sky
oh yeah oh my god when they say the
quote mortality is home entertainment
like i dived so deep into that into
being like
i am literally you know the 27 club i'm
like when i make music i'm like yo
i was just talking to someone like i
picture my life
as a train on a track and i'm far away
from home
and i'm headed home okay and i want
all of my influences to jump aboard my
train at any point while i'm on that
track
and be able to ride with me and use me
as a vehicle and as
a vessel and like i so believe in that
and like the whole
idea is like life is entertainment is
just like yes it's entertaining and it's
also entertainment for something else
you think so totally watching me like a
script yes
oh man that's a fun thing to think about
do you see all the alien stuff that
comes out these days and do you get all
jacked up and excited and going
they're here i'm ready take me i'm ready
beam me up scotty serious experience um
i would say like six months ago in
joshua tree with a guy named dr steven
greer
have you heard of stephen greer yes oh i
know stephen i know steve and i okay
i went to joshua tree with him like six
months ago
okay tell me about it because i'm
tempted to do that sitting
in lawn chairs in the middle of joshua
tree in a circle with stephen greer and
doing a puja prayer
and all the stuff and um let's just say
like
yo i saw it yeah
i saw it and we had contact like no
confusing right no [ __ ]
no like no it's not web service but you
literally saw it
what did you see orbs man orbs what did
you see um
bursting orbs of light uh you know
a lot of this stuff he was ex he was
explaining to us in in terms of like
we're [ __ ] down here that are like
don't enter our earth or we're gonna
shoot you down i mean are aliens real
yeah yeah they are like who
stop being stupid people like this
this is a big giant play we're not the
only game in town come on
and like how much fun are we down here
of course they want to join the party
bro they're like
duh so like you know i want to hang out
with mod
yeah so like we're sitting there and you
know i'll just say one experience that
like that like happened for sure is like
the temperature you know when you're
sitting out there asking
for these things to it was a really
beautiful thing because
it's going in my
in my i guess in my terms what i was
getting gathering from this experience
was that
alien life is is um
they're kind of scared of us they think
that we're we're
so uh frightened by them or
shocked or something so when you're
sitting there and you're saying
we come in peace just simple as that
we are not here to exploit or
shoot you down or hurt you like you're
accepting them into this world
and like definitely one thing that
happened was like we all
felt the temperature around us
raised by like 30 degrees literally when
you're in the desert at night it's cold
right
so like the temperature raised so high
that we all started sweating but it was
in the matter of like 10 seconds
and what we all saw was this giant ball
of light
completely encompass us and what he was
saying was we were taken aboard a ship
and like time exists in a completely
different way so what felt like to us
like the snap of our fingers
was like come on that that could have
been so long and
we i mean like stellar right yeah and
they have
oh my mind [ __ ] and like he had a
temperature gauge with him
and like it was recorded that the
temperature rose in those
matter of five seconds by like 35
degrees or something
um exponentially and like we all saw
this burst of light
around us and like um you know
i could go on and on about like just
seeing other little things but that was
like
the defining moment of being like oh wow
like this really happened and like i do
believe
that um i do believe that other life is
is down here walking amongst us you know
i believe in reverse technology more
than anything like the story of valiant
thor that goes back into what like the
50s
like about you know how look at how our
technology has just
vastly gone through the roof and it's
like i believe in reverse technology of
of another lifetime
source being like here's a computer
take it apart and you will know how it
works i don't know what i'm doing
yeah like that's what i asked even too
is that some of the stuff that we see
like i live in arizona so it's like
hotbed i keep hoping i look up and see
something cool um because they happen it
happens here all the time
but i asked him i was like do you think
that it's actually our own technology
um reverse engineering what we've found
crafts and
and and seeing how it works and and yeah
is the answer
um i like i get this like so you know
looping sort of old life new life in
there's
uh you know i i think it's a really
brave and um uh confident thing
to talk about how you used to you know
look and idolize certain people that you
know
came and went too quickly and you know
the things
the things that we fixate on and put our
perception on become our reality
and so i keep hearing cool stories
about things that you're manifesting and
experiences you're having
and how some of these things probably
wouldn't have been possible without
a new sort of point of perception and so
um what kind of things have come into
your life over the last couple of years
that
uh you're so grateful for that are
totally different like weren't part of
your old life
yeah and for people listening that don't
know it's you know
having addiction and going into recovery
and
you know spending a lot of a lot of time
sort of spiraling to different levels of
addiction
and then to come out of that and be in
the place that you are now with such
perception of reality and yourself
uh and and all these new experiences and
being able to be present for them
that that like boom boom you just nailed
it
it's like it took me
so long to become present you know i was
so fixated on the future you know
there's this great quote that says um
depression comes from the thoughts of
past
anxiety comes from thoughts of the
future and like
if you can live in the present you can
somehow avoid those
things and um so my my
story is the person who was
a hundred percent like i was addicted to
drugs i was
a extreme cocaine user like
through the room um all day every day
for a massive like eight years
um to the point that it almost took my
life and i and and what what it really
did to me
um because i do love like i think you
can gather that just by talking to me
for the last 20 minutes i love life i
love experience i
love this place i love people and i love
myself
and like every time that i would do
like that i was like this is gonna kill
me
and i was carrying around this suitcase
filled with shame
every day just walking around with this
suitcase of shame
and like is cocaine bad to do
yeah yeah it is it's a drug it's bad to
do
um you know what's worse than that shame
self shame it will hold you back
from all these beautiful things that
life wants to give you when you
feel undeserving of something
you are putting a red light on your
entire life
and i would get so close to the finish
line and then i'd say
yo i don't deserve this [ __ ] because i'm
i feel bad
like am i saying anyone out there who
does cocaine am i saying you're a piece
of [ __ ] you're a bad person
[ __ ] no not at all if you feel bad
someone was asking me the other night
bro did your life change because you
quit that [ __ ]
and i'm like i'm pretty sure just quit
because
my life changed because i'm not carrying
around this self-shame